J'ai aussi remarqué
qu'en relevant des défis de 30 jours plus nombreux et plus difficiles,
j'avais de plus en plus confiance en moi.
Je suis passé du mordu d'informatique collé à son bureau
au gars qui va au travail à vélo -
juste pour le plaisir !
L'an dernier, j'ai même entrepris l'ascension du Kilimandjaro,
le mont le plus haut d'Afrique.
Je n'aurais jamais été si aventurier
avant de commencer mes défis de 30 jours.
J'ai aussi découvert que si vous voulez quelque chose à tout prix,
vous pouvez tout faire pendant 30 jours.
Avez-vous déjà eu envie d'écrire un roman ?
Chaque année au mois de novembre, des dizaines de milliers de personnes
essaient d'écrire leur propre roman de 50 000 mots en partant de zéro
en 30 jours.
En fait, tout ce que vous avez à faire,
c'est d'écrire 1 667 mots par jour
pendant un mois.
C'est ce que j'ai fait.
Au fait, le secret c'est de ne pas aller se coucher
avant d'avoir écrit vos mots de la journée.
Vous manquerez peut-être de sommeil
mais vous terminerez votre roman.
Est-ce que mon livre est le prochain grand roman américain?
Non. Je l'ai écrit en un mois.
Il est horrible.
Mais pour le restant de mes jours,
si je rencontre John Hodgman à une soirée TED,
je n'aurais pas à lui dire :
"je suis informaticien".
Non non, si je veux, je peux lui dire : "je suis romancier".
(Rires)
Je voudrais dire une dernière chose.
J'ai appris que quand je faisais des petits changements durables,
des choses que je pourrais continuer à faire,
il y avait plus de chance qu'elles persistent.
Il n'y a rien de mal à se lancer des défis de taille, des défis fous.
En fait, ils sont très amusants,
mais il y a moins de chance qu'ils durent.
Quand j'ai arrêté le sucre pendant 30 jours,
le 31ème jour ressemblait à ça.
(Rires)
Alors j'ai une question pour vous :
qu'attendez-vous ?
Je vous garantis que les 30 prochains jours
seront bientôt derrière vous, que vous ne le vouliez ou pas.
Alors pourquoi ne pas penser à quelque chose
que vous avez toujours eu envie d'essayer
et tenter de s'y mettre
pendant les 30 prochains jours ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)